here we go we go so this is almost final
draft of the cover we've got our own
boxes produced we've got our own
cartridge mold produced those not too
upset Saiga we've got our own logos on
them big evil corporation cartridges
thirsts so the physical side of it is
nearly ready to go want you to do now is
finish the game we caught up with you
how long ago was it I finished the first
level which is split into three acts and
it's got most of the main mechanics
running thank you a bachelor when the
Kickstarter right it was mid Kickstarter
yehud Kickstarter yeah yeah yeah and
obviously for those who haven't seen
that video your Kickstarter was
successful which congratulations thank
you very much wait with it then what's
happening with the game um yeah it's
taken just over a year so far to get to
this this point from the Kickstarter
we're about 90% finished there's a few
audio things to fix up some bugs and
it's going to head for closed beta
testing so I expect in the next couple
of months we should have our gold build
I understand things took off quite
recently with yeah you got a bit of
exposure when perhaps expect yeah I did
an interview for the BBC I had a PR
campaign planned to drop at the same
time as the video it went a bit earlier
than I expected I was on my way to an
event called play Expo in Blackpool and
I got a phone call saying that was on
the TV so I have to quickly pull over on
the motorway at the Starbucks and
quickly launch our website it was a bit
of a hairy move have you had a lot more
interesting start there
yeah it's been quite manic the past
couple of weeks since that interview
went life how other people contact me
for magazine interviews and videos and
podcasts and things like that it's been
non-stop for the past couple of weeks
let's be frank now did you quit your job
for this yes I did quit my job for this
for better or worse so what's what's
going on long term then long term once
we finished up releasing the Megadrive
version we're going to port it's the
Dreamcast and then it's coming to modern
consoles hopefully if the publishers are
on board with it after that we've got
another two games up our sleeves so we
can do this all over again
you're saying we and does um you work
with people on this are they sort of
like characters you work with all the
time or yeah for the first game I work
with some contractors
it was mostly myself making the game
though for the next one I'm not sure I
could stomach it again so I think I'm
gonna hire some stuff we see quite often
people indie games producers getting
stuck in a rabbit hole of working on
their own game for years and years and
years how do you avoid that do you know
you don't but you know I suppose the
question is it looks like you're getting
near to completion so it feels like
there is light at the end of tunnel
where as we hear of games getting stuck
in development hell for want of a better
word is do you think this is something
to do with the limitations of the
devices you're working on rather than
yeah I think that play some part and
there's only so much we can do on the
rugged drive and we can't upgrade the
graphics engine we can't add much more
to it we're out of ROM space we're using
all four megabyte of the cartridge so
there's nothing more we can do to the
game we've got no space in Ram ROM we've
got no CPU cycles left we've maxed the
whole thing out which is a both a curse
and a blessing because we have to say
this is it now we've got to polish this
up and release it and feature creepers
is not an issue here
when's the when you slated for release
what's the latest kind of ETA the plan
is mid 2018 where we're penciling in
late May early June at the moment
and it has its own set of registers
these aren't general-purpose registers
for adding numbers and stuff each one
has a specific purpose so one will be in
control of the background-color 16 to d1
so we can see that d1 changes to 16 in
hex and then add the two together